good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast ladies and
gentlemen and
happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the weekend weekend
Friday Friday getting down on Fridays
that was literally like Little Mermaid
and yeah you're going into Little
Mermaid it's a remix it's a Friday she
does it all she does show tunes she does
pop she does Jazz what can she do mash
up is there anything cooler than a
mashup literally no that's the best
episode of Glee
DJ earworm
DJ earworm later on ended here mashup if
you don't know the DJ earworm end of
year mashups I can't help you I just
can't jack if I could send you to
YouTube if she doesn't know the end of
your mashups by DJ earworm she's too
young for you bro
literally
Margo knows the mashups yes okay okay
that's good that's definitely
that's so funny like gen Z thinks
they're cool and stuff but they didn't
have DJ earworm no gen Z didn't have a
lot of things oh my God we sound like
such desperate pathetic [__] losers
like no no I don't think so because like
we're not trying to say like we're
better than gen Z in any way like you
know I'm gen Z's big sister I'm just
saying like they missed out on DJ
earworm yeah I just I personally like I
think talking about like generations and
like Trends and like who's better is the
lowest form of conversation I think it's
like for actual like morons
okay
um I'll keep that in mind moving forward
but I just feel like I wasn't falling
into that no no I just didn't want to
start having that conversation I like
nipped in the mud
okay cool yeah you torched it you didn't
nip it in yeah I burned it to the ground
you did you did but as you were singing
before it is Friday which is a most
joyous occasion congratulations everyone
we've made it to the weekend it's a
Cause worth celebrating that and the
fact that Jackson Claude are back on the
ones in the twos OG recipe
OG recipe Audio Only but still exciting
nonetheless you've had an exciting
family week at the toast I saw Ben was
hosting yesterday
Fanfare we had an amazing week
yeah we did you know you always think
you get like the the big stars the big
names it's always exciting it is but
honestly nothing slaps better than an
actual family week at the toast I think
moving forward like whenever you need a
day off I'm gonna tap into family
because you know I also we have your
maternity leave coming up so I need to
save that's why I didn't want to like
reach out to all like The Heavy Hitters
um because I'm gonna need to ask them in
a few months or whenever so I I think
I'll stick to fam
yeah I think it's working and people
love the satchel and they love Ben and
they love the cratchle
and they love the Macho and most
importantly latchel
oh my God latchel is so underrated
completely gray
completely agree
how are you doing on this Friday morning
oh just blessed I mean it's Friday truly
what more could you ask for did you want
to get plans I like I did oh I keep
forgetting to update everyone on like
this journey I'm on um I did make
weekend plans that were kind of
predicated around me picking up my car I
was talking about this a few weeks ago
about how I was really thinking about
getting a car you know I live this
really kind of untethered life I have no
Financial assets I'm like this 30 year
old woman with like nothing to my name
sorry 28. and
I made the decision and I've been going
through the motions I forgot to keep
everyone updated on the process but I
did I'm getting a car and I thought it
would be ready for pickup like today or
yesterday but then I had to like I
realized there's so much to do like
Insurance all that stuff so it'll
probably be like Monday or Tuesday so me
and Ben were like gonna plan a weekend
away we're like we have our car we're
gonna pick it up on Thursday and let's
do something for the weekend but the
car's not ready therefore I can't go
anywhere
got it
okay well keep us posted so you're not
doing anything this weekend you'll be
seeing me I'll be seeing you and all
that song is so sad it reminds me of the
notebook
what song is that
um what song is that hold on I actually
don't know the name I only know that one
line I'll be seeing you the notebook
in all I feel like it's Etta James no
Billy Holiday same thing oh wow not you
singing Billie Holiday on the toes you
don't know that song from The Notebook
Billie Holiday I love him literally I'll
be seeing you in all the old familiar
places I'm sure if I heard the song I
would know it but I'm not knowing the
one line
okay don't be rude like no no I'm not
don't be [__] rude I'm being like
just truthful okay I'm so glad we're
being truthful
do you have any truths that you want to
share today I do actually
well I wanted to tell everyone about I
had the most fun evening last night
um because obviously like I went to a
fabulous place but I felt so fabulous
like I kind of took a risk with my
outfit which is normally something that
would ruin my night like I'd get there
and be like why the [__] did I take a
risk like I should just wear black like
I it's something that would ruin my
night but I was still feeling my look I
like a few days ago I like decided I was
gonna wear this like kind of crazy
outfit this like skirt suit what do you
call that like Blazer and skirt it's
like a matching set yeah it's not like a
pant suit but it gives like pantsuit
energy
ish
um from Veronica beard that I had like
been targeted for on Facebook like a
thousand times I'm like I think I could
wear that and I just love the way that I
looked so I had such a good time like
feeling myself I'd gotten my hair done
like I was feeling good even though my
bruise like was on my forehead even like
it was so upsetting I had this big night
out and I had this bruise
it's getting better from what I see it
is getting better but it's not gone
but when you see it does it like remind
you of Harry and the good times no
shared no actually if it did I could
live with it but my the association is
not there the association is you are
such a dumb [__] yeah yeah that's what
I think of when I look in the mirror now
which is so great for my self-esteem
well it's on its way out yeah you'll be
back up in no time and I will be that
self I will be kind of missing it
because what else am I going to talk
about once my bruise is gone
it's true it's been so great for Content
yes for content
maybe you'll have to do it again
um so last night I went to Haley Bieber
through a little dinner party for the
one year anniversary of her skincare
brand road which I'm actually a really
big fan of like I couldn't get any when
it came out and Margo got all of it and
she was like so annoying about it like
did you try like the glazing cream I'm
like no [__] shut up I didn't get it
um and slowly I've accumulated pretty
much the whole collection and last night
I got the whole collection in a gift bag
I do have some doubles I'll bring them
over to you because oh thanks I have a
lot
um but you know like I was so nervous
about the gift bag I was like I put it
on the floor next to my seat and the
whole night I was looking I'm like is
someone gonna take my gift bag I was
like really concerned about it because
that [__] is hard to get for sure but
that would have been crazy if a guest
took a gift bag that they also got like
they needed double well some people like
are like insane like that and take
doubles and some people like would be
like oh that's mine no [__] it's mine
no
um so by the way it was so fun and I
just have so many thoughts like I had a
great time once again because I was like
feeling my looks second because I got to
like sit with Simon and Phil like it was
just like it was a gorgeous evening and
I was so like honored to have been
invited at first I thought it was um
like an influencer but I think a lot of
celebrities do influencer events dinners
parties cocktail whatever to promote
their brand and that's what I assumed it
was and when I walked in and knew nobody
I was like oh my God Pittsville USA and
then thank God Simon and Phil were there
and it was so fun it was really just
like Haley's actual like friends and
family celebrating this you know major
accomplishment having a skincare line
being really successful one year in
and it was amazing and I had met Haley
before and we've like you know dm'd a
bunch but we had never really hung out
and I am here today like on a mission
you know a few years ago I met Gwyneth
Paltrow and my my immediate
reaction was rage actually because the
amount of like things people say about
her and just the public perception of
her you would have assumed she would act
a certain way and when I tell you she
couldn't have been more amazing and
genuine and lovely I was inspired I was
motivated I was on a mission to like
change the narrative about Gwyneth
Paltrow and I actually feel through my
work but also like other things that the
narrative has changed around Gwyneth do
you agree that that was like the
conscious uncoupling days and people
were just like she's out of touch I'm
like no she's a queen yes and also I can
say for firsthand you changed my
perception really oh for sure okay look
at me yeah yes making changes in my own
Community even if you own helped one
person it would be enough jayeno
um and I'm feeling a similar way because
I was so like taken aback by Haley
obviously in person she's you never saw
like a more beautiful human being in
your life it's actually disgusting like
that like it's it's actually not fair
like she's so radiant and she's
obviously like beautiful but I honestly
think
so much of her beauty like She Glows
from inside she could not have been a
more kind sweet lovely person and it
wasn't a facade you know and like a
celebrity is like you know making the
rounds she is like in her she's a doll
wow I'm obsessed I feel very passionate
that she's another one very
misunderstood you know and you know how
like we live in this age where
everything she does becomes a trend it's
like she has you know white nail polish
and it's a trend and you know what she
really it's not it's not like a thing
she's she's just the way she carries
herself so naturally like that's who she
is like she's that [__] and I'm
obsessed with her I love that for her
for you and now for me because I'm very
influenced by your thoughts on people
also she's so beautiful so stylish but
last night I saw a picture of her like a
Paparazzi picture before like when you
were on your way to the event and so is
she and
she looked unreal like the best outfit
I've ever seen in my life yeah and
honestly I was like a little concerned
like maybe I was gonna be overdressed in
like my you know first lady type of
laser but when she walked in like tens
tens tens across the board I was like no
I'm perfectly dressed
yeah you know it's really never a crime
to be overdressed it's like oh I respect
you in this your event so much I wanted
to give it my all exactly yeah sorry I
care too much yeah I would rather be
overdressed than underdressed but I
don't know what the rule of thumb is
it really I I used to feel I would
rather be underdressed because I think
underdressed means like oh I don't care
that much but it's also like a little
rude
yeah but would you rather look a little
rude or like oh a loser but now I'm
thinking like being overdressed doesn't
make you a loser
like trying too hard I don't think
that's a loser equality
caring caring trying too hard it's like
caring I don't think it's a bad thing to
be overdressed and also you could always
like just look and act as if you're
coming from somewhere nicer be like
sorry I'm so fabulous I'm booked back to
back I was at a nice event and then I
came to hang out with you slobs you're
welcome you're welcome
um and she was just like a very good
host she was like passing around trays
of margaritas shots of 818 you know we
love a loyal friend and it was just a
really fun night you know you go to a
lot of things like that and like they're
really never fun it's just like work
um it was not work I looked in my phone
I was being such a bad like influencer I
didn't even know where my phone was but
I just because I was having so much fun
that's so great and I was it was really
just like an honor to be nominated
I'm so happy for you that you had a
great night you looked beautiful thank
you so much Jax I loved the outfit you
know how I like it by the way I was
actually thinking so many people this
were saying this outfit is so Jackie oh
I wasn't sure if they were referring to
you or the first lady because it tracks
for both
for both I agree but now that I've worn
it and like I got a bunch of pictures in
it it is 100 yours
yeah that's so sweet thank
you and you know what I actually have
two sizes so whichever one fits is yours
okay I'll reach out in a year I'll have
my people reach out to your people I'll
put it in storage until you're ready
stop don't be mean sorry was I mean no
it's just like no you just think I have
space for not one but two pantsuits oh I
forgot you're the sweeper that you can't
just like hold on to things no if it
doesn't serve me in the next week it's
out of my house and if I need it in two
weeks I'll have to figure it out then
I'm gonna say something so real like
you're the sweeper and you won't keep
things in your house that are like not
useful but like I saw your shoe wall
yesterday
and it's filled with shoes that you
would never wear and that you never wear
facts and that you won't be wearing
facts facts across the board and what
are you doing with them all right I'm
not a perfect person I never said like
sweeping made me perfect I just like I
like to sweep I like to like get rid of
things declutter you like to pop and
lock and jam and sweep I like to pop and
lock and jam and sweep
yeah but I feel like you could do your
shoes next
there's by the way there's a lot of
things I could and probably shouldn't do
in this life and that doesn't mean I'm
gonna do them one thing about me I have
no problem with my shoe wall yes part of
it is that like I'll have the shoes on
my wall I will quite literally never
wear or maybe I've worn once but I like
the way that it looks like it's it's a
design thing because you like it because
hmm I like it
now I know you're being like Bad to the
Bone today with your hood up while we're
FaceTiming but can you please put it
down because your microphone keeps
rubbing up against it oh my God you're
you don't like my hood no I love your
hood but I'm hearing like all the
friction from your microphone oh my God
you're like kind of being toxic today
and I need to maintain my mental health
okay whatever you say toxic
am I being toxic
I think if you have to ask
I'm only asking because you said it no I
just look like if you have to ask if
you're being toxic like you probably are
I don't think I am I don't think what I
asked for was so crazy just like to hear
but like a voice first it's the
microphone then it's what's next my
kidney
I would give you a kidney though like in
a second I don't know if you'd want mine
I don't think it's like probably like in
the best shape but no I would take yours
yeah like if nobody else was around I
don't think I'm like I would be in a
position to be choosy yeah yeah I always
think about that like I was reading a
book where like somebody needed a liver
or something not a liver probably a
kidney
um
and I was thinking like would I do that
like for a member of my family 100
but like even then like I would really
hope somebody else would step forward
yeah I don't know what the procedure and
the recovery is like but I would do it
for my family like no questions asked
except for what's the procedure in the
recovery like that would be my only
question no questions asked except like
you are going to be nice to me for the
rest of your life right yeah what's in
it for me right
can I borrow your shoes in exchange
yeah could I have that Veronica beard
outfit you can for the price of one
kidney
good to know yeah
um we've got a good show today what
would you say in terms of the stories
the stories are good they're they oh
they're it's weird it used to be like a
Monday stories would be really strong
and Friday there would be nothing but I
feel like Friday there was tons and
Monday there was nothing so there's been
a reversal of the Fates a reversal of
the Fates I feel really good I'm excited
to chit chat with my swirly yeah what's
going on
um I chose the stories obviously like
the last two days or whenever it was
Tuesday and Thursday and it was one of
the hardest things I've ever done no
it's getting harder and harder Claudia
I've been trying to tell you like I feel
like in the past when I've tried to pull
stories like the first three come like
decently easy and then you like scrape
the bottom of the barrel Daily Mail like
fourth and fifth CNBC you know CNN Money
um however I couldn't even find like a
first story
yeah that's where it's been recently
yeah it's the summertime you know let's
just hope this is a trend
summertime in the lived in zzzy
that's like a caption that people use
like for Instagram when it's summer and
I know that if you use that caption
you're automatically unoriginal
duh no now that I said that I'm gonna
make it my caption but like I'm gonna be
doing it like in an ironic like pick me
kind of way
okay I'll pick you every time turdy live
check stop I love you and I'm so toxic
right beyond that was the most toxic
thing you'd ever said
I think that was so supportive it's like
yeah Claudia is a pick me girl but I'll
pick her every time okay for sure but
like I'm really not
no not in your heart of hearts like
pikmi girls are like oh my God I can
really only hang out with guys and like
I love beer no like you joke like you
joke about
wanting to be chosen yeah but but I
think in your heart of hearts you're not
you're like please skip over me please
don't notice also at its core pick me
girls like that phrase comes from like
girlies especially in like college in
high school who just wanted to be picked
by guys like that's not what I want I
just want the attention of everyone like
not men yeah that's true
that's where I think there's a key
difference so what's the word for like a
pikmi but who is you know gender
inclusive thirsty thirsty
okay I'll take it
okay I think without further Ado we can
get right into the fast five stories
that you need to know
support for today's episode comes from
one skin if you've ever thought to
yourself what if we could reverse the
root causes of Aging then listen closely
our new sponsor oneskin puts science and
research first founded by a team of four
female PhD level longevity scientists
with over 15 years of experience one
skin set out to not just decrease the
visible signs of aging but to treat the
root causes of skin aging I'm talking
essential face moisturizer I topical
supplement and a topical body supplement
to keep your body moisturized so your
skin doesn't look younger but it
functions younger like a healthier skin
should so how one Skin's products are
formulated with their os01 peptide as
the primary active ingredient to support
the Skin's ability to resist the effects
of intrinsic and extrinsic aging factors
their Flagship product oso1 face is
clinically proven to strengthen the Skin
Barrier and improve key skin Health
markers meaning signs of aging are
significantly diminished so one skin is
a fabulous brand personally I love the
body supplement I feel like we're always
talking about ways to have our face look
snatched and young forever but the neck
and the chest is where you really can
see signs of aging and I love that they
have a body supplement treating the
symptoms rather than the root causes of
Aging has long been the norm most skin
care available on the market is designed
to provide a temporary reduction in
visible signs of aging addressing just
the surface symptoms but leveraging
their in-house cutting-edge r d platform
they were able to measure the efficacy
of age reversing molecules in their Lab
One skin is the world's first skin
longevity company they address skin
Health at the molecular level targeting
the root causes of Aging so skin behaves
feels and appears younger it's time to
get started with your new face eye and
body routine at a discounted rate today
get 15 off with code toast at oneskin.co
that's 15 off at oneskin.co with code
toast we only have one body one skin and
only you can choose to make it better
age healthy with one skin
episode is also brought to you by roback
I think it's safe to say everyone is
talking about these guys whether it's
their performance hoodies their polos or
their q-zips we always make sure to
recommend rollback for the man in your
life if you want your man looking good
then get him in row back by the way
Father's Day coming up I'm sure a lot of
you have forgotten you haven't gotten
the man in your life whether it's your
father your husband baby daddy something
for Father's Day Grandpa Grand don't
forget Grand there I have amazing
options at rowback
um now we're excited to recommend their
uh ladies options so robek just relieves
to active skorts and dresses and we are
obsessed they're perfect for a day on
the courts a walk with your dog a nice
jog on a summer day the active dresses
feature their trademarked GTG technology
so that you don't have to take your
dress all the way off when you gotta go
to the bathroom the liner also doesn't
ride up it has great stretch and hidden
pockets for all your Essentials I have
to say I love their squirts I love a
squirt it's such an underrated piece of
clothing for summertime for chafing for
literally everything I love their
squirts the roback women's joggers and
Hoodie sets are literally the softest
pieces of clothing that we own if you
want to be comfortable then these
joggers and hoodies are for you we
haven't taken them off since we received
them they're that good so with Summer
quickly approaching make sure to check
out roback and while you're at it we
strongly recommend treating yourself as
well so use code toast on roback.com for
a generous 20 off your first order of
performance squirts joggers and hoodies
that's spelled rho
b-a-c-k.com that's 20 off with code
toast foreign
thank you Claudia you're welcome our
first story is actually some big
podcasting yes
Prince Harry and Meghan markle's Spotify
deal is over spotify's exclusive deal
with Prince Harry and Megan has come to
an end with the couple having delivered
just one show under the agreement
Spotify and archwell audio the couple's
podcast production shingle said Thursday
in a joint statement that they are
ending their pact quote Spotify and
archwell audio have mutually agreed to
part ways and are proud of the series
that they made together in my series I
believe it was 12 episodes of Megan's
show archetypes and then that one
holiday episode of archwell
remember that when we first announced
when they first announced the deal then
they came out with like this holiday
episode I think it was Megan and Harry
it was one episode of something talking
about stuff and then they didn't put out
anything for like almost two years and
then she started doing her podcast got
it um
which was like a one season thing and
there's no more so I think um they
didn't meet the threshold for output
yeah for their deal and so I mean 20
million dollars for 12 episodes is
insane well I have to imagine that that
they didn't get the full 20. I don't
think you get the full 20 upon signing
there's like deliverables and benchmarks
you have to reach
um
so I don't think they they got the whole
thing but I also Imagine they got
probably half like you get a big chunk
on signing and then once you do the
whatever so I'm sure they got like a
good amount of money and I'm sure it
probably didn't return on investment for
Spotify because I don't think the show
was like incredibly popular I also just
don't think it was what people thought
it was gonna be no and also like even if
the show was incredibly popular like how
can 12 episodes of anything equal 20
million dollars back in spotify's Pocket
yeah
it's not enough content no it's not even
like a show like even a really really
big huge show with like five or six ads
and they're getting like a ton of
downloads I think really the most you
can generate through like one episode of
a podcast is like a million dollars so
if you're only doing 12.
yeah but it wasn't even about the ads
like I think with Spotify they make
their money back because you bring in
membership subscribers yeah
yeah there's yeah there's a few ways
that's true
so it it the show had hit like number
one when it launched
but it wasn't like gangbusters it was
just a pop a very popular podcast on
Spotify which again like it's limited
because people can't listen to it in
other places no and it's hard to measure
the success of a Spotify podcast against
like the success of all podcasts because
like you're
um you're gonna be high up yeah you're
gonna be high up on Spotify where other
people a third of Their audience listens
on Spotify right you know what I mean so
you can only really compare it to like
fellow Spotify exclusive shows yeah
which are always in like the top 10 on
Spotify which makes sense I feel like
this is like two-fold I think there's
really two interesting conversations to
be had here the first is like this is
really the first project or thing that
Megan and Harry put out that like wasn't
about their experience in the royal
family and it kind of flopped and I
think that's probably like a thing
they're thinking about is they obviously
don't want to keep talking about it but
like when they do the book gangbusters
you know so how do they move forward but
also continue to like create content and
be relevant and and create a living
without keeping talking about it
had like a few weeks ago that they're no
longer going to be talking about the
royal family stuff mostly because
there's nothing left to say like they
did the docuseries they did Oprah she
even would talk about it like here and
there on the podcast like in terms of
just labels that the media put on her
his book so they've they've said they're
no longer talking about it which makes
sense because there's nothing left but
then I think the other part of this
conversation which I find like actually
more interesting is there was like a few
years where Spotify like clearly decided
they wanted to be the number one app for
podcasting it was always apple and they
spent like an insane amount of money
taking a lot of shows exclusive creating
a lot of original shows on their own
with like famous people and I think a
bunch of them have paid off I probably
think like the most obvious one is Joe
Rogan but I think there's like a few
flops and like kind of bad Investments
and I feel like this would be one of
them it was a good idea like I don't
think anybody could have really
predicted that like they wouldn't come
back for a second season that it would
be two years delayed and that it would
be like just like a random show just
like interviewing other people just like
everybody else like I don't know any if
anybody would have predicted that but I
think this is like one of the the
Investments That Spotify made in people
that's like now kind of backfire not
backfiring but just like didn't pay off
yeah I agree plus Spotify did lay off
200 employees earlier this month from
their podcast operations I don't know if
that was the story or we just it wasn't
but I did see two percent of their
Workforce yeah so it's not just like
they have all this money that they can
give to celebrities and people of note
and that they don't have to like earn it
back yeah there are consequences for
like overspending but I do think a lot
of their efforts to become the top audio
listening platform have borne fruit like
that a few years ago we used to look at
this our podcast like we push we have
our podcast everywhere and the majority
of listens would be on Apple I think at
one point like four percent four percent
with Spotify then nine percent and now
it's a third yep
and that's like through all the work
they're doing yeah no I think and I
would probably say they are the number
one place for podcasting no they're not
no like in the culture like no when I go
to listen to a podcast like
I now like 50 50 go to Apple or Spotify
I go okay I go to Spotify if there's
video yeah and I feel like sometimes
it's a Spotify exclusive show so I have
to go like right no like when it's not a
Spotify exclusive show like I just went
to go listen to skinny confidential I
went to Apple yeah no they're fruits the
labors of their fruits have definitely
paid off but not definitely born fruits
but not every single thing they did was
like a hit and now I think it's just
interesting to see what ended up being a
miss
yes I agree and I feel like more stuff
like other
contracts and stuff are going to come up
soon and will they renew or not right
like how long was the Joe Rogan one for
it was a few years ago 10 years oh okay
I mean yeah he literally got like 100
million dollars I think maybe more so
and it started but it started in 2020
so but I think 10 years just based on
like how I perceive things
I would say that that's a you know a
fruit that's bearing fruit or whatever
you want to call it based on like yeah
it's like the charge his his episodes
are like one two three and four every
single day yeah old episode like yeah
um armchair expert is exclusive to
Spotify now yes
they chug along nicely yeah they do but
then there was also like Spotify was
creating their own shows like Spotify
Originals like Addison remember Addison
had a show
um they had like a bunch of like good
celebrity Duos and almost all of them
are gone like that was something that
didn't work for them I think more so
acquiring existing popular shows is
gonna be the way for them to go
obviously call her daddy too yeah but
that's the same template of like
acquiring existing popular shows because
really with celebrities like you think
oh this person's a huge celebrity
they're gonna start a podcast it's going
to be so big
but most of the time it's not yeah it's
not I think for a really long time
people thought it was like a perfect
formula like a celebrity and a
microphone like we're gonna be rich
but it's not you know who's someone
who's actually very interestingly I've
been seeing her podcast everywhere and I
think it's really doing very well and
I'm sure she got paid a lot because I
think it's a wondery created whatever
Julia Louis-Dreyfus
yes I've been seeing it everywhere too
because it's like been put everywhere
but I also am seeing it like in the
charts legit yeah
um and because she's like a star and
she's like a a smart like thoughtful
well-lived person and well like like for
her personality because she's a comedian
that's why it does go better for
comedians than you know like the
smartless guys right like it it can work
it's not
it's not like nobody wants to listen to
celebrity podcasts like they do really
well but also it's like they do really
well at first like let's give it a few
years yeah well that's what's happening
with these contracts like with Spotify
so it is a very interesting time to see
I would I mean I'm sure we'll never know
but I would love to see just like a list
of like what made money for Spotify and
what didn't you know
yeah well not even like made money
because I do think like there's a lot of
different ways to measure success ways
to measure success and some of it is
just like you know Impressions and what
are we talking about and all of that but
just like numbers who's listening to
what well that's a really interesting
thing about podcasting when you compare
it to like YouTube format which I think
was like the previous long form content
um you know you could see everyone's
numbers and like people were competing
and like wanting to get more reviews and
more subscribers all that's public with
a podcast you have literally no idea
unless it's your podcast how another
podcast is doing so it's really easy to
make your podcast look like it's
crushing it but nobody knows
yeah and it's easy to make it look like
your podcast is crushing it except for
the charts but the charts are now a
little muddied with Spotify because you
can't compare the Spotify exclusive
shows like you can't compare them with
the shows that go everywhere right so
you could look at Apple charts but that
doesn't include Spotify shows right yeah
and apple podcasts don't even
really
like the formula for Apple podcast is so
weird like you don't have a million and
be number one and then the person under
you has 900 000 of that episode it's not
strictly numeric it has a lot to do with
like reviews and subscribes like it's so
the algorithm is so Random so it's still
not even an easy way to measure it yeah
it's still not well in this Variety
article a source close to the situation
with Harry and Megan said they they
wanted to move away from their exclusive
Spotify distribution to find a new home
for their audio projects
which I don't believe
um but so we'll know based on whether or
not they keep podcasting right right
like if they go to you know Sirius or
whatever
or if they podcast like every other Joe
Shmo and they put it everywhere right
right
because they want more distribution like
like you don't leave Spotify exclusive
no that's like that's where everyone
wants to be it's like the mecca that's
where everyone wants to be and you do
get the protection of like
we don't know how successful you
actually are right because we're a
Spotify exclusive right no very
interesting like four-year Saga in the
archetypes universe
yeah so I think I saw now they're just
down to their Netflix contract right
right but I think also Harry still has
two books in him yes contract yes
but he needs to wait that's the thing
it's like
unless he wants to write a work of
fiction
a smut book
I think you should write Royal smut yeah
kind of like red white and royal blue
Vibes yeah which you still haven't read
but you need to read I know because the
show is coming out on Prime you should
read it first just in case it shows bad
yeah no and like I want to be a part of
like what everyone's talking about and
everyone's talking about red white and
royal blue
you know what book I started last night
what Minka Kelly's book
oh anything good yet yeah it's so well
written and it's still in her childhood
which I know you hate and I actually
think the whole book is like her that's
what I've heard her life story but it's
such an interesting life story and she's
just had the craziest experiences that
yeah what's her like what's where was
she born like she's born she like lives
in Hollywood with her mom who um they're
like in and out of friends Apartments
boyfriends you know people's garages I
think her mom like was between jobs like
working as a
um
um like a peep show dancer and um
chauffeur like whatever but then at one
point like her mom goes to take a job
like acting on uh in the Philippines and
so she's like bouncing around between
like people like not even her mom's
friends just like other people's houses
how old is she she's like seven and then
she's nine and it's but she's like such
a like a smart sweet precocious little
girl who's just like trying to get
through and it's just it's really well
written and it's crazy like the amount
of success that she's had yeah does she
is she like still close with her mom
like was her mom
she's I don't know yet I
I don't know she's only like 10 I just
got to part two right right I'm so
curious like if after like everything
you know how hard her mom worked if she
was ever able to see like Minka become a
star yeah because really close when she
was little but obviously she wasn't like
the conventional right parent
um
so it's really good I would so far very
much recommend it oh good it's on my
list
yeah and I feel like it became like I've
heard from so many different
people and sources that it's such a good
book not just like one person
recommending it but I've just been
seeing everywhere that it was like
really just like a sleeper Memoir and
it's so good and you should read it and
so I was finally influenced interesting
all right I'll think about it I gotta
get my book club book started
what are you guys reading the rose code
oh yes I'm excited for you it's like
kind of you know it's not my usual thing
so it's taken me like a lot of mental
gymnastics to even open it up you know
I think you'll like certain elements of
it and overall the story is like amazing
okay
but Prince Philip's in it oh no way it's
about like the girly before Elizabeth
oh I didn't know that but it's that's
not the whole that's just like a piece
of the story God it's not the it's not a
love story about like you know he just
happens to be he's like a is it the
ballerina character
an affair yeah okay cool yeah yeah it's
cute so there's some Elizabeth adjacent
things you'd love to see it
you do are you ready for our next story
yes
so Priscilla Presley says that Elvis
would be proud of the Trust settlement
with Riley Keough we had reported that
there was strife
among the women Presley
um after Lisa Marie's passing but
Priscilla believes that her late
ex-husband Elvis would be proud that she
reached a legal settlement with her
granddaughter Riley Keough AKA Daisy
Jones
in a declaration filed Wednesday and
obtained by people the 70 or 8 year old
said she's pleased that she and Riley
can finally put their legal tussle
behind them the pair reportedly reached
a million dollar settlement this month
over Lisa Marie Presley's estate who
died on January 12th she said my
daughter's passing was both devastating
and heartbreaking we have learned that
the fans realize that we are just a
family Elvis would be proud and his and
Lisa's wishes are are what are most
important to us so I believe that the
settlement that they agreed to was that
she would give Riley would um give
Priscilla a million dollars in order to
become the sole Trustee of Lisa Marie's
estate and then another payment of four
hundred thousand dollars to cover her
legal sees So Lisa Marie left her estate
which is technically right like Elvis is
to her daughter Riley
and that wasn't cool with Priscilla
yeah I think like Priscilla had
wanted to be a trustee as well and I
think maybe at one point she was and
then it was switch and like maybe she
didn't know
so she was like fighting Riley it's like
a weird situation like it is and I'm
glad that it's like over over with and
that both parties can be happy with the
resolution I just like don't really know
how you come back from that no I was
gonna say like in a family way how like
do you think these two are cool
it's it's just a little awkward no money
makes everything like cringe
yeah like how do you actually like move
forward with your grandmother when you
just pay your grandmother 1.5 million
dollars yeah and like Grand was like
coming for you you know and like the
roles are reversed like it's like it's
weird for both of them because you know
it's a grandmother's supposed to
basically and give money and an
inheritance to a granddaughter not the
other way around so it's like it's weird
for Riley that like her Gran is suing
her but it's like weird for her grand
that like her grandkid has all of her
money like it's weird yeah yeah
yeah
so I'm glad this can be put behind them
I'm sure Riley's thinking to herself
about her and her grand like how did we
get here how do we get out that's
probably that's probably what she's
thinking 1.4 million dollars
not too shabby even though I think in
like the grand scheme of the um estate
it's not a lot no
it doesn't seem like it it feels like
Penny's on the dollar
yeah
yeah to be young
well speaking of iconic singers are you
ready for our next story yeah
Paul McCartney announces the final
Beatles record with AI restoring John
Lennon's vocals
The Beatles are coming back thanks to a
Little Help from AI in an interview with
BBC Radio 4's best of today Paul
McCartney revealed that he employed the
technology to create what he calls the
final Beatles record we just finished it
up and it'll be released this year the
song will include vocals from the late
John Lennon who was killed in December
1980. AI was able to extricate Lenin's
voice from an old demo it was a demo
that John had worked on we were able to
take John's voice and get it pure
through this AI then we can mix the
record as you normally would do so it
gives you some sort of leeway
no that's definitely cool you know I
feel like remember a few years ago when
like the trend was like dead celebrities
doing like hologram tours yeah this is
like the new wave of that the hologram
thing was like actually a little creepy
and weird
um I guess this is like a little creepy
it's different
um it's cool you know it's cool for the
fans
I don't know
it's a little I mean in this one
instance I think it's it's fine it's one
song It's the final song he had a demo
of it out there like it's not that
far-fetched but I think it's the
precedent that it sets that like anyone
posthumously can just be like cranking
out tunes and who's gonna be in charge
of what these Tunes are and if they are
congruous with the person's Legacy yeah
I mean then it speaking of Priscilla
like it it's all back to the estate like
the person who owns the estate or like
owns the Masters to that person's life
like then it becomes like legal I'm sure
John Lennon's a state or trustee whoever
it is like who owns his whatever needed
to approve this
you can't just be Rogue releasing
people's [__] posthumously without it
but also it's like I think the Beatles
are the entity here you know yes but I
think you know each Beetle will then
gain financially from this
will
hold all their stuff yes who owns
Michael Jackson right Michael Jackson's
estate owns The Beatles Masters
so he Michael Jackson's getting money in
the grave too
posthumously yeah
I think it's just a can of worms it in
this instance like sure let's hear what
the Beetles have to give us in 2023 but
you know but AI is a can of worms no
yeah and like do you think that the song
is going to pop off in the way that it
would have had been released at the peak
like have has has music trends like
moved past the Beatles well people like
people will listen for like the novelty
for sure but like will it be a Bop
I don't think so I I think it's going to
be sad
yeah
until you know like Diplo makes a remix
or whatever yeah if they want to yeah
exactly but then it's not like the
Beatles no then it's like new age crap
yeah
open but
they no this is like a cool thing about
AI you know everyone's talking about Ai
and like to be honest I don't know
enough to like have a full flown
full-fledged conversation but there are
a few things that like AI can do that I
actually like I'm here for like this is
cool
what else are you here for well there's
a lot of um AI software programs that
are making like video editing and
podcast editing like so much more
seamless and easy and like that's cool
yeah yeah that's cool and it makes it a
lot cheaper I mean then it's but then
the conversation is like for you know
content creators it's making it a lot
cheaper a lot more accessible to like
get quality content out there but then
it's putting you know people who edit
video and audio for a living it's
putting those people out of business
yeah
I'm not putting them in my business but
like taking away jobs yeah that taking
away jobs but robots have been doing
that right that's like that's the
culture this is just the next that's
just this is the next iteration of it
that's what robots do
they'll keep you unemployed the whole
day through
funny but it's not 100
well are you ready for our next story no
no no
no our next story is brought to you by
Lululemon Lululemon shorts were made to
stretch flex and support the infinite
ways of working out giving you the
courage to LEAP into something totally
new and unexpected Lululemon as we all
know is the One Stop Shop for everything
you need this summer also year round but
anything when you want to work out
athleisure Lululemon's a place so it's
officially like leg bearing season and
all the shorts we're loving are from
Lululemon I love the hottie hot short
it's their short with a comfortable
range of motion and a really flattering
fit they allow you to Max your stride so
you can move freely with confidence
they're lightweight Swift fabric lets in
airflow so you can move without all the
baggage and they're designed to Wick
away sweat before you even notice that
it's there you can carry your Essentials
with two perfectly placed discreet
Pockets things with pockets are
everything in discreetly placed pockets
are my favorite kind of pockets I also
really like the Wonder train short it's
the short with supportive stretch that
keeps you dry it's powered by the
everlux fabric the Wonder train
collection manages heat and sweat so you
stay comfortable and focused it's sweat
wicking quick drying the fabric absorbs
moisture and Wick sweat during even the
most intense training and they have
great shorts for men Father's Day coming
up the pace breaker short is their
versatile short that is up to any
challenge each pair of pace breaker
short is designed to Wick away moisture
so that all that's left is your
intention it has Secure Storage which
means you can keep things close without
feeling them bounce around so get into
Lululemon shorts at lululemon.com that's
l-u-l-u-lemon.com Lululemon shorts are
the One Stop Shop this summer for your
undercarriage needs
thank you Claudia and I actually have
something to say before we get into the
next story which is that I want to
introduce you to a product that over
half a million parents including Moi use
to help their baby sleep the Dreamland
baby weighted sleep sacks and swaddles
it started with Tara a mom who couldn't
get her baby to sleep we all know about
that life she was exhausted frustrated
and searching for answers ain't that the
truth her solution was to create a
gently weighted sleep sack that your
baby can wear safely to help them feel
calm fall asleep faster and stay asleep
longer major key the award-winning
doctor approved dream weighted sleep
sack is the only sleep sack that
features cover com technology evenly
distributed weight from baby's shoulders
to Toes that naturally reduces stress
allowing your little one to relax and
sleep soundly just like how we big
people use a weighted blanket to help us
sleep and reduce anxiety and just make
us feel common at peace these Bebes are
using the Dreamland weighted sleep sacks
and swaddles
so I love the Dreamland sleep sacks and
swaddles Harry cannot sleep at night
without a sleep sack I didn't get these
ones until recently though we've had
them for a few months because Harry was
going through her sleep regression and I
was like we need a fix and I did a lot
of research and I heard such great
things about these Dreamland sleep sacks
and swaddles from mamas that I know like
so it was very trusted recommendation
and now I'm so glad that they're a
sponsor on the toast so I can share them
with all of you but I also think that
they are so great during the newborn
phase I've also heard from some of my
friends when babies like don't have
control of their arms and they're kind
of flailing the Sleep sack that
Dreamland has like you tuck their arms
in underneath the zipper so it makes
them just like so cozy and comfortable
the best news is that they're offering
an exclusive discount to the toast
listeners just head to
dreamlandbabyco.com Pages slash toast a
news code toast at checkout to get 20
off and put your sleepless nights to
rest
that I say to me yeah welcome dead
our next story just some young handsome
people doing young handsome things Jacob
elordi and Olivia Jade spend time
together on the beach in Italy obsessed
Jacob and lordy and Olivia Jade are on
vacation in Italy and the pair were
photographed spending time together
Under the Sun they were seen soaking up
the sun in paragy definitely not how you
pronounce it near Portofino how would
you pronounce that if it's spelling
p-a-r-a-g-g-i
yeah for sure after relaxing on the
beach and going for a dip they were
spotted riding through town on a
motorcycle it's just too much no it's
literally a movie
I think these two are so well matched so
well suited I couldn't be more
supportive of this relationship they're
both so good looking it's quite
literally not fair and I'm so happy for
you know young beautiful people to be
doing young beautiful things yeah
and I'm glad that there seems
more next serious step in their
relationship I feel like they're always
just like walking the dogs in their
pajamas and I'm glad that they got out
of the house and like traveled out of
the country it brings you closer
together as a couple yeah this is
definitely a really big step I love that
we got these Paparazzi picks I'm so
happy for them I I just can't say enough
good things about these two like I think
it's a perfect I honestly if they went
on are you the one it would be a perfect
match
yeah it would be the truth booth
confirmed the truth booth confirmed
these two are a perfect match
yeah so I just hope they keep doing what
they're doing but like there's not much
else we can say about this you know yeah
and like she's 23 and he's 25 so like
I'm not even waiting for like an
engagement or something just keep on
keeping on I love this I love this do
you think he's met like Lori and Massimo
yes obsessed
yeah I do
let's leave it at that I don't want to
jinx it like I don't want to get too
excited you know because then tomorrow
I'll be reporting they broke up and like
his show got canceled yeah like they
didn't travel well together you know
about that life like he wore his
backpack in the airport and like she and
like she got sick because she couldn't
go to the bathroom in the hotel right
and they just saw it like it just it
wasn't worth doing it anymore yeah
so our fifth and final story is actually
going to lead into a little TV recap
wait just really quick I do feel like
celebrities are like immune to a lot of
icks that normal people might suffer
because like Jacob already is not
wearing a backpack through the airport
they're flying private someone's
carrying his bag for him they really are
that's a like a privilege of celebrity
that not a lot of people talk about is
the lack of icks they don't wait in
lines okay yes I agree that they
wouldn't suffer from like traditional
icks but then I'm sure as a celebrity
there are like celebrity specific icks
yeah like publicist oh you didn't get
the invite right Vanity Fair Oscars
party ick yeah no I like that oh you had
your publicist place that spotting of us
ick you're so right you know what I mean
it's a new it's a different Stratosphere
of x
has their own things that they struggle
with 100
our fifth and final story is going to
lead into a TV recap because we're
finally getting to the meat and potatoes
of the Kardashians on Hulu and the Riff
between Courtney and Kim So Courtney
slam Kim for copying her wedding with
the dng show
Kim's Dolce Gabbana deal didn't sit
right with her sister Courtney in
Thursday's new episode of the
Kardashians Courtney accuses Kim of
copying her Italian wedding
which was hosted by dng in the episode
titled ciao Kim Courtney tells Kendall
she was hurt after Kim chose to partner
with Dolce mere months after her May
2022 wedding to Travis Barker So
Courtney got married in May and the
fashion show was in September she said
so Kim is in Milan you know doing this
whole Kim Dolce Gabbana Chao Kim living
La Dolce Vita whatever she said to uh
Kendall she added that when she decided
to work with the designers on her
wedding it wasn't even about business
it's not like I did their campaign and
she did their campaign right after it's
my actual wedding this wasn't a business
deal for me I did it because it felt
really personal Courtney said Kim always
has such an abundance of opportunities
for Partnerships but that pursuing the
Dolce deal seemed to take precedence
over hurting her sister it's just legit
copying my wedding pointing out that she
pulled references from Dolce gabbana's
90s archives when it came plant time to
plan her wedding outfits and then Kim
did the same for her collection
it's a really interesting fight because
it's not a hundred percent clear who's
right and who's wrong I do feel like
Courtney is not doing a good job of
explaining why she's mad and it just
seems like confusing and she's coming
off like maybe a little
um like bitter with like not posting the
t-shirts or whatever but I do think she
makes like a fair point but I don't know
how it I don't know how it is applied
here it's like she the point she was
making about like this abundance and
just like this life of excess excess or
however the [__] you pronounce it I feel
like I actually understand that it's
like at what point like is it enough
um but I don't really know what that has
to do with her wedding
oh I that's not the point that I took
away from it
um
like there was a part of what Courtney
was saying that did resonate with me
more than I thought it would because I
don't remember our reaction when we
found out that they actually there was
an issue over the Dolce thing but it
kind of made sense but I think for corny
it's like within the family like she
brought Dolce to them at least that's
how I we see it as consumers we don't
know like the back end of how it all
went down but like for the last even 10
years in fashion like Kim's been wearing
like these futuristic things like just
doing a total different vibe with her
style and Courtney brought the whole
family into like this Dolce fold had
this whole Dolce weekend and like it was
amazing for the family and no you're
right the way I felt watching the
weekend I was like oh my God why don't
these girls dress like this more often
like it was like classic like feminine
Silhouettes where it's like Kim's always
wearing like a space suit and alien
glasses yeah and Courtney like did kind
of in no I don't want to say like invent
but like did bring that to the family
and like that was the vibe of her
wedding and so I think she she was more
offended that like The Vibes of her
wedding were then copied and like
commercialized which I don't I think
maybe her and Kim could have
communicated better but I think at the
end of the day like Kylie said Kim still
should have done the show yeah it's too
big of an opportunity to pass up so I
think like maybe she could have handled
Courtney's feelings better but I do kind
of understand what Courtney I don't even
know if she was saying this but it's
like I did this one thing and it's kind
of like the first and biggest thing that
Courtney's done where it's like it's
actually like Global impact and it was
like it's so original it was so original
I felt like for me like it was the most
interesting and invested I'd been in the
girls in like so long it was just so
gorgeous yeah and then like not even six
months later like Kim makes it her own
no you know it's like you're actually
really changing my mind whereas for
years she's been in the fashion industry
she's had access to all these designers
and like she never once was a Dolce girl
no
but she didn't seek out this opportunity
she did want to push it Dolce wanted to
work with her so like it is what are you
gonna do what do you really what are you
gonna do if they had maybe a better more
um
where it's like I know that like you
love me and you respect me but like get
your bag and do what you have to do yeah
they don't have that sort of like if it
was Chloe and Kim like this wouldn't be
a thing and it's like Rising Tides rise
all shides and it would be great for
everyone but like a part of me did
understand like Courtney had one thing
yeah like you know and and now it's
Kim's no you know what you've totally
changed my mind on it like you're 100
right and I think it the issue because
Kylie's right like Kim there was no way
Kim was gonna pass up this opportunity
and she Sure Shot you nor should she and
it doesn't make her greedy for for
taking it like this is
uh nobody gets to curate a fashion show
made of archival looks for like an
iconic fashion house like that's unheard
of but I do think the situation wouldn't
have even been a thing if the root cause
like if their relationship was even
remotely better like there were a lot of
rumors like a little while ago that like
Kim and Courtney weren't talking and it
was like this conspiracy that like they
were not even you know friends anymore
and I think a little bit of that that
was dramaticized but it's definitely
like rooted in truth and I think they
have this like really um
not [__] up but they just don't see
eye to eye on anything they are so
different like I think Kim sees Courtney
as like this Downer and you know not
hard worker and Courtney sees Kim as
this like greedy almost and just like
when is it going to be enough and like
you don't prioritize the same things
that I do like we don't prioritize
family like I think they really judge
each other for the life choices that
they both made and so if that wasn't
like at the root of their relationship
this might have been been able to be
like handled in a much better way
yes like they don't communicate like
they don't care
yeah and also like after Courtney's
wedding like all of those like Dolce
like was selling out on every like I
remember I was like on farfetched like
now I want some Dolce dresses like it
was just like it just became very
popular very quickly so I understand why
the
brand would want to like continue and by
the way remember we like literally a few
weeks or months ago actually were like
was like Corey Corey Gamble did like a
dinner with Dolce like the whole family
is now like Dolce Living La Dolce Vita
yeah but I I want to know how Kim's
collection did yeah was it like was it
worth it like what was the goal of it
but I was just she said she wanted to
sell out globally like when it launched
all these like re-freshed looks yeah
well I was on farfetched and you can get
all of like I literally saw everything
that was in the episode oh it's like not
sold out Joel J Kim yeah I don't know
how you measure success from something
like that is it like Impressions because
it if it's that like Kimbra we were all
talking about the show and she did it if
it's like buzziness and press then that
is a success
yeah
I don't know
I don't know either I
unreal but I don't think I realized like
what they were doing together me neither
it was archival looks that she had
carried I just thought like she was the
face like the face of Dolce same same
but it is a really crazy fight and it
feels very real
yeah no and I think it's like still like
lingers between them and I genuinely see
both sides whereas before this I think I
would have said like I think Courtney's
being
um crazy a little bit sensitive yeah and
I I saw her side more than I expected to
no you know I do still think at the end
of the day like who would ever say no to
this if she can't get no time by the way
Courtney said that Courtney said like I
would never tell anyone not to do
something but like to not account for my
experience and my feelings as a sister
like that is hurtful but Kim felt like
she did like I feel like for Kim so she
didn't choose from the Madonna
collection or the lace collection
because we're really close to Courtney's
wedding but then Courtney was like she
did the 90s look so I guess like
Courtney's looks were within the 90s but
like it's like where do you draw the
line on what's copying like do you get
the Whole Decade or do you get the
collection no that's fair and I think if
it wasn't four months later she could
have done whatever she wanted
yeah
but Courtney's probably like riding this
high of like her wedding being like this
Global Affair her doing something so
different than literally any wedding
ever like it was really so good for
everyone she's probably like still
riding the high and
now it's just like her sister and it's
like it's always about Kim and I don't
think he's like yeah like dng came away
from the wedding and was like we want
Kim because honestly in a perfect world
Courtney's the bride it's Courtney's dng
weekend like then she goes on to do a
collection with them yeah but that's
like not how the family works
and that's how much wanted
yeah no that it's you know what you've
really totally changed my mind like I'm
actually feeling like like
a little sympathy for Courtney I'm
feeling sympathy for Courtney because
it's like I had this whole weekend this
was my vibe and Kim upstage her because
Dolce wanted her no and then it just
like goes back to being the Kim show
like it always is
yeah and this one thing that was like
made that was so cool for Courtney
honestly and so personal because it's
still outside she was saying this isn't
business it was my wedding right
and then it's like but they want Kim
still so I understand being hurt by that
but it's hard to like
be a big girl and say that that like
yeah
especially because and Courtney said
this like in an episode recently like
when they were growing up there was
always this competitive Vibe and
Courtney's like I've moved on from it
but Kim hasn't but it's clear that like
Courtney hasn't moved on from it so just
to acknowledge that there is like a
weirdness and a competitiveness I don't
think she wants to do so it's hard to
explain herself when she won't just
bring in that element
interesting it's it's
a thing I also think the whole stylist
thing with Kim
a lot of people are kind of um flummoxed
by
yeah I was flummoxed yeah how like Kim
you know for Gears has been this like
style Queen and she's like Queen of
fashion and fashion this fashion that
Kim Kim and
to see how rattled she was to like do
these meetings where she's just like
styling pieces without her assistant was
shocking I'm not assistant excuse me
stylist
yeah it was and but then it was like
this Arc of you know Triumph I did it
now I don't even need the stylist
yeah which dress for the final do you
like better you know what I know nothing
about fashion so I'm gonna go with the
look that's like more commercial and
like boring and it was the one that Kim
liked but I'm sure like The Stylist who
has this like Rolodex and like well of
knowledge on style I'm sure the other
one was technically more stylish but I
just like the other one no the way I
felt about it was like Kim's dress that
she was wearing was classic Dolce like
beautiful and that's what Dolce is like
feminine Silhouettes beautiful period
this dress that the stylist chose was
like very much Kim Kim Dolce yeah with
her PVC plastic which is like so Kim
Yeezy Vibe but in a Dolce silhouette
like it really was a more of a merger of
the two of them yeah but is that what
the whole collection was supposed to be
I didn't really know what the what the
like um
for lack of a better word like what the
point of the collection was like I just
on the show I don't think it was made
clear like is this Kim's influence on
Dolce is it dolce's influence on Kim
like what was it supposed to be
I think it was DJ earworm mashup yeah
well then in that case the second dress
was better but I do agree with you there
is something that's lost and like what
is this who is this for and it's I think
reflected in the fact that like it's not
sold out yeah and I think the idea that
they almost did like a skims Dolce
collab would have been gangbusters
especially when you think about bendy
schemes like that [__] sold out in hours
online and it was resented so it's like
what this didn't no and that was so good
for Kim and Courtney had no issue with
that
oh yeah but aside from Courtney it's
like
I don't know I don't know
I don't know but it was it was really
beautiful to look at obviously she looks
unreal and I loved the blonde she was
and I and I'm grateful to Courtney for
ushering in this era of just like these
gorgeous feminine looks and Silhouettes
because Kim was like made for that yeah
and it's so the opposite of like the
Balenciaga spandex looks that are just
not my favorite Speed Racer alien
spacious yeah literally
yeah great POV jacks
I was surprised by how I felt yeah
because I think in the past
with like the the conversations where
like Courtney's kind of the outsider
like having an issue I haven't agreed
with her so I'm just used to not I'm
just used to not I'm just use yeah I
agree
I'm just used to not which was why I was
like oh and yeah but it was like I think
a lot of people were like shocked like
Courtney starts breaking down and
Kendall's literally just sitting on the
other chair not moving like your
sister's crying why don't you like rub
her shoulder or something like yeah but
I feel like Kendall's not like that
she's like not very emotive and neither
is Courtney actually
I don't know I feel like Courtney's Loki
always crying the thing is it's like I'm
not very emotive but I'm low-key always
crying you know such a good point that's
an amazing point right but like if
you're crying do you want someone to rub
your shoulder you feel like to me in
court similar to Courtney and like the
sensibility way
of like you mean being like very tactile
yeah like so if if you're coming but she
like used to like rough house with Chloe
like wrestling and stuff like that would
never be me no she's changed
yeah
it was a good episode
it was my girl Kylie was there so cute
so cute riding horses giving us nothing
we live for it giving us nothing like
her way of contributing is just doing
the like plot the B plots
yeah the bee plots which I can't believe
in all the years of them doing the show
like they Kendall and Kylie can't find a
better narrative for themselves and like
Kendall wanting to hang out with Kylie
and Kylie being like too cool for her
yeah it's
it's giving up everything at the same
time what the plot was like when they
went on that trip with Tyga yeah like
years ago yeah like their relationship
right it's totally sad it's always kind
of being like I want to spend more time
with Kylie yeah it's like give it up
sister she doesn't want to hang like
she's not interested like an interval
they should fight about it
yeah I think they do I feel like they do
even remember last season when like
Kendall went to Vegas and the whole time
she's complaining that Kylie's not there
and it's like she gave you her plane she
just had a baby all of your friends are
there have fun no totally it's really I
didn't even like put it together it's
the same thing they've been fighting
about since they were like 17. yeah it
must be like nice for Kylie that
everyone's obsessed with her yeah within
like she just does nothing and like
shows up to ride a horse
Queen obsessed obsessed so that's TV
recap anything else you want to chat
about before we head into the weekend no
that's all from me that's all she wrote
oh she wrote pencils down pencils down
thank you so much for listening to the
Justin Monday Morning Show where we
deliver the fat Side Story anything to
know everybody through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available to
podcasting our podcast can be found on
Spotify iTunes District public radio I
heard a cat box all the places review
about a beautiful stunning and wickedly
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing weekend there is no show on
Monday as it is Juneteenth so we are
back on Tuesday for a gorgeous episode
we love you dearly and we'll see you
then love you bye